and finally new row let's put a trigger
warning on trigger warnings
Jenny from Flinders University analyzed
a dozen other studies on trigger
warnings and they all came to the same
conclusion they don't work not only
don't they protect your feelings but if
you actually have been traumatized by
something they're warning you about a
trigger warning makes it worse it's like
if seat belts were made out of broken
glass
it winds up just being a reenactment of
the old joke how do you keep a in
suspense I'll tell you later
now for those of you who have been
living on an offshore oil rig for the
last 10 years and don't know what I'm
talking about a trigger warning is a
kind of close your eyes Here Comes an
ouchy
that like so many bad ideas in recent
years got started on college campuses
students started demanding them so they
could get ready in case something in a
book or a piece of art or a history
lesson reminded them that life included
bad things and not just good and
sometimes people were mean
you can't have that just sprung on you
several universities in recent years
have even compiled lists of words we
should be warned about to get rid of
altogether including balls to the wall
no can do you guys Master white paper
man in the middle off the
reservation peanut gallery insane and
virgin
we can't say virgin as opposed to what
person experiencing not getting laid
thank you
you would think that one would take the
care the cake for the oversensitivity
but these students at Brandeis said hold
my baby bottle
they made a list of Expressions they
don't want to hear because they remind
them of violence terms like killing it
beating a dead horse and yes even
trigger warning
I guess they don't teach irony in
college anymore
at some point the trigger warning
escaped from canvas and got out into the
real world and now they're everywhere
warnings at the top of Reddit threads
and Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
posts warnings before your favorite
serial killer series before news
articles Disney put an advisory on the
movie Dumbo
warning viewers about stereotypes
because otherwise you might think it was
a documentary about flying elephants
Turner Classic Movies still wants to
show you classic movies but before we do
first there are a few parts we'd like
you to feel really bad about
now enjoy the show
theaters do it now too the storied
Guthrie Theater in Minneapolis tipped
off their crowd that a play included
simulated gunshot strobe lights and Haze
Haze
Casey has been groped by a thick fog
a sitter in Brooklyn alerted the
audience to expect moments of darkness
and violence and this was for Oklahoma
my senior class in high school put on
Oklahoma and I thought it was corny and
provincial then I cannot I cannot
imagine the fragility of someone who
needs to be warned about it how do these
people get to the airport let alone
through childhood
London's Globe Theater felt the need to
tell the audience that its production of
Romeo and Juliet include suicide
okay but Romeo and Juliet has been in
your Netflix queue since 1596.
[Applause]
you've had 400 years to prepare and also
it does kind of give away the ending
I don't I don't understand how a society
that's so in love with spoiler alerts
can also be into trigger warnings tell
me what's going to happen but don't tell
me
and again all the research shows that
these trigger warnings don't even work
what they do is reinforce the idea that
trauma is Central to your identity and
that you should let it Define you
instead of dealing with it dispatching
it and moving beyond it people wonder
why the younger Generations have so much
anxiety it's this stuff lots of stuff
makes us uncomfortable you know what
makes me uncomfortable this
people
people who start every conversation with
as a person who as a survivor of I'm
triggered every time I see a trigger
warning
because I'm reminded of how weak my
country has become it's like wearing a
mask on your mind
we keep finding out about new health
problems kids have from being locked
inside for three years exposed only to
filtered air during the covet era turns
out that's not healthy but you know
there is an alternative way of dealing
with anxiety and let me put it in comic
book terms so the kids can relate
Bruce Wayne you're familiar
was afraid of bats so what did he do he
became Batman
that's the way to go
because honestly we cannot go any
further in the other direction we've
been going in we've already passed the
point of parity a student group in
Australia recently called for trigger
warnings on eye contact even the Taliban
are okay with eyes
[Applause]
eye contact will you traumatized as a
child after losing a staring contest
what's next trigger warnings for
conversations having everyone walk
around with name tags that say hi I'm
Dave please don't bring up doorknobs
ah
[Applause]
I'm Josh I have a drug problem and a
hairy back so don't mention cocaine bear